all
right thank
you thank you thank you enough enough
you sexy people all right so as the Gaza
War rages and Iran threatens to enter
the frey President Biden jetted off to
Israel now we don't know whether Biden's
trip helped but if he climbed the steps
to Air Force One without a face plant
let's call it a
win but first let's do some history the
truth is the Middle East always exposes
the naive of past democratic presidents
back in 79 President Jimmy Carter took
American credibility into Bud Light
territory when Iran seized 52 American
diplomats he looked weaker than cat at
LA
Fitness yeah no it's okay yeah it's all
right true it took over a year for
America to respond which we finally did
by electing Ronald Reagan and that was
after an aborted rescue that crashed in
the desert oh those Democrats they want
to abort everything but eight US service
members were killed then and it was
really bad in 2000 Bill Clinton held the
famous Camp David Summit between the
Israelis and Palestinians where he
learned that no matter how much he
pleaded yaser Arafat wouldn't go down as
easy as Monica
Lewinsky so did he they rejected more
proposals than me at that nudest Colony
Barack Obama was convinced he could make
a difference he thought Iran could be
brought around from a fascist theocracy
to a friendly Modern Nation if we could
just get that pesky nuclear deal done so
he sent over John KY in $1.7 billion in
cash they should have sent Hillary just
to make her shut up and cover her face
but but the money part they understood
Obama brought hope and more than a few
bags of change then watched helplessly
as Iran built up bigger arms than his
wife's look the mid East the mid East is
probably the most politically screwed up
place in the world many of the the
issues go back so far Larry cudow was
still in
school he's he's so old he helped build
the
pyramids he supervised in fact the Old
Testament Quran and the Torah each have
a verse where Abraham says Wake me up
when you people get your
together but one of the basic reasons we
care about this place is a single word
and that's oil especially for Gavin Nome
who smears it on his hair to trap
seagulls for food the truth is no matter
how much how much green talk we hear
from the likes of AOC the technology to
run the world on butterfly farts just
doesn't exist yet if she had her way
we'd freeze this winter as she stays
warm in her Tesla yet thanks to a
Democratic party that has made green
energy a religion America has gone from
the world's leading energy producer to a
nation jonesing for another shot of that
sweet Saudi soda into our veins and no
matter how much Dems try to bribe Iran
into liking us it's not going to happen
cash gifts words of praise it didn't
make me return Taylor Swift's calls and
it won't work with the
Mullis which brings us to the present
Biden offers six billion to Iran in
exchange for American hostages that
Hamas sees more American hostages right
afterward like stairs speed bumps and
sandbags Biden never saw it coming but
even Helen K could connect the
dots she's been dead a
while it's sort of like leaving 7
billion dollar in weapons in Afghanistan
which end up being pointed at our allies
you know if only Afghanistan had gun
control but I think they call that cause
and effect I guess they don't teach that
in gender Studies classes so now we're
caught up in all of this again America's
greatest foreign policy thinkers have
sharpened the points on their ivy league
dun caps and formulated a new MID East
plan the historic don't
Doctrine my message to any state or any
other hostile Act
don't don't don't and anyone thinking of
taking advantage of this
situation I have one word
don't don't don't don't
don't I guess Biden speech writers have
him down to one word
now at least he can remember
it worse when referring to the hospital
Carnage he calls Hamas the other team B
on what I've seen it appears as though
it was done by the other team not not
you the other team like it's pickle ball
how diplomatic I guess it's an
improvement over calling Isis the JV
Squad it's always the Dems now it's been
said that foreign policy is picking
among the least bad of your choices and
with zombie Joe in charge there's more
bad choices than the Taco Bell dollar
menu but time for some credit where it's
due because you know who actually moved
move things forward in that department
that's right the great Satan Donald
Trump and over there you know that's a
compliment who was the first to actually
meet with the little rocket man in North
Korea before that who had we sent Dennis
Rodman you know while the left was
screaming that Trump just had to be a
Russian agent guess what we had no
Russian Wars and while they were
shouting that his son-in-law Jared
Kushner had no experience and foreign
policy it was Trump and Kushner that
brought in the Abraham Accords which
normalized relations between Israel and
some of its Arab neighbors of course
normal is now a relative term like
woman the left couldn't believe it
Donald Trump the Diplomat what would the
UN say besides lesbians can have
penises if you'd watch the show you'd
know it was also Trump that made America
the greatest energy producing Nation on
Earth giving us the leverage over the
Middle East to try to change things that
tilted things in our favor faster than
Gerald Nadler getting off a
seesaw and Trump had ran so scared they
offered to take John carry back but but
of course the Geniuses in the Biden
White House had to blow it all up we're
back to trying to bribe Iran into
behaving again hey it works on Joe Biden
and we're back to buying some of the
dirtiest oil on Earth from some of the
dirtiest regimes on earth like Venezuela
and also Saudi Arabia whose leader
Prince Muhammad bin Salman made our
secretary estate sit for hours before
blowing him off all while Palestinian
leader mmud abas announces he won't even
meet with Biden when he arrived in
Israel fortunately that won't keep Joe
from trying to shake his hand
anyway this president's foreign policy
is falling apart like the Patriots
without
Brady it's true true hey you think maybe
Dennis Rodman is
available cuz boy do we need a rebound
right about
now let's
welome tonight's guest he employs a Sapp
of 20 and that's just to help him pick
out a tie host of making money on Fox
Business Charles
P you've probably seen him sitting on a
stack of gold bars HOSA cudow on Fox
Business Larry
cudow
like this speaker of the house old white
men fight over her too New York Times
bestselling author and Fox News
contributor catch
[Music]
him and he learned to duck as a toddler
New York Times best-selling author
commedian and former NWA world champion
[Music]
Tyrus Charles by the way congratulations
on your new book it's called unbreakable
investor look at that snazzy cover thank
yeah I'm going to read this tonight in
the hot tub with
Larry Larry should read it to you yeah
oh my god I've had that fantasy Charles
where do you want to go with this tell
give me your thoughts uh first of as
you're going through you know it just
struck me I don't I think we're
misinterpreting when he's saying don't
don't don't I think he's trying to tell
everyone around him he has to go to the
bathroom really it's like someone get me
I have to
go they say you can't say do do cuz it
sounds too obvious
don't don't yeah I was thinking about
Clint Eastwood the whole time like you
know you feeling lucky punk like it
wasn't quite the same but it was all you
know like feeling lucky punk you know
yeah but he never said Iran yeah that's
the thing he and you you spoke to use
the word naive and not
naive if Hamas steals the stuff we send
over we're going to be upset
MH yeah yeah as soon as it gets you it
belongs to Hamas are you kidding me
don't be stupid let's let have an honest
conversation about this you know first
of all why did you go you did not have
to go there right now at this present
time Israel's got their hands full yeah
right they they really did not need
President Biden over there uh it's
always the public relations department
of the White House that dictates what
happens yeah it's like when you have
like relatives that decide we want to
stay for the weekend but you know you
it's you got a tough you got a tough
Monday ahead you don't really need them
to stay on the couch that's a terrible
analogy
Larry all right you work for president
Trump how do you feel that
Administration would have handled this
differently is that too is that too
unrealistic a question no I mean look I
thought your intro was fabulous on this
point and I think it's a really
important Point um when Trump left the
White House there was peace in the
Middle East and there was prosperity in
the Middle East when Trump left the
White House Iran was broke and China
wouldn't dare to buy any oil because
Trump laid down a marker when Trump left
the White House the Middle Eastern Gulf
States were were aligning with Israel
instead of attacking Israel at every
turn he also put the embassy in
Jerusalem where it
belongs he would never have allowed the
kind of uh Retreat from Afghanistan
which is probably what started this in
the first place and Putin would have
never dared to invade uh Ukraine that's
what helped start this in the first
place so the differences are Stark and
one of the worst parts of this entire
turn off your phone I'm so glad that
wasn't
me someone was trying to order the book
I'm
[Laughter]
sorry Larry but one of the starkest
parts of this is that Joe Biden and his
group are in complete denial look I'll
give look Biden has supported Israel
right I'm G to give him credit for that
so far he has supported Israel okay good
good good but what's not so good Iran is
is the terror Master the finance year
the Puppeteer and the planner okay they
are in complete denial about what they
have done they have made Iran rich in
the last three years and that rich $80
billion dollar of oil revenues for
starters has now been distributed across
the Middle East with all these terrorist
groups including Hamas Hamas never would
have done this if Iran didn't say yes
Iran would never have said yes if they
hadn't gotten rich in the last three
years and the bidens for some insane
reason are completely in denial about
this maximum sanction should be you want
to help Israel let the IDF do what the
IDF is going to do and restore maximum
sanctions on Iran bust them turn them
into bankruptcy those two things will
help solve this problem quickly there
you go all right
cats I'm anxiously awaiting your
thoughts what say you about the this
state of affairs I mean what I don't
like
it good good I think you're going to get
some angry mail you're going to get some
angry mail on that right uh look I think
uh you you your monologue covered some
of it but there is a long history of
American failures in the Middle East uh
there's a long list of ways we've tried
to intervene in the Middle East and then
how things have gotten a lot worse and I
think that we need to remember you bring
them up Afghanistan there was never any
accountability for any of that there's
really never any accountability when it
comes to military um so those are a lot
of the same people who they're asking
what should we do here were're the same
people who were responsible for that so
I hate to say it but I don't feel very
optimistic I am a little concerned about
World War II and I really I I don't
think that that's a good idea I really
don't want to see a global war you're
coming out against World War III I am
all right but honestly I think that that
might be a controversial take right
now I'm offended yeah Tyrus last word to
you
okay um I don't have my script with me
yeah there is nothing more
inspiring to anyone who's thinking about
doing something bad than the paint the
main the boss the leader of the Free
World witing and trying to remember what
he's saying yeah you know I believe it
was the
U Don't
yeah also that's what he said the other
team I guarantee you it was like don't
mess with America there's an old saying
you mess with the bull you get the horns
yeah and then he got out
there
don't don't
his and he keeps telling the same stupid
story okay look I'm a comedian cat
comedian you're a
smartass you sometimes you tell a joke
that you think is phenomenal and it's
not you don't go back to it yeah he
keeps telling that story of that one
time he was in Israel yeah and an alarm
went off and he's what do we do what do
we do and this lady came out of the Mist
in the fog and said it's going to be s
right and he's like how can you say that
they going be shooting missiles at us
because we have nowhere else to go we
have nowhere else to
go what in the blue does that mean I'm
nobody was anybody inspired then was
like we've got nowhere to go yes be like
we've got to do
something we're stuck here waiting to
get missiles dropped on us yes it's
we're laugh We Are The Laughing stalk of
the world every time he speaks he
encourages everyone I myself thought
about committing crimes today I'm like I
was watching his speech and I started
thinking hey I think judge Denise got
some jewelry
in and then he said don't don't that was
enough that's all it took the best thing
was he was only there for S hours
because they tricked him they said Mr
President it's been two weeks oh I got
to get back all right we got to move on
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest inter inters and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else